did you uh play football growing up oh
yes sir how good oh I like to lock up I
started a little late playing football
there's a lot of fun i love the tackle
do all that stuff but then played in
high school what position did you play
Oh Defense Advanced not about it oh my
god i didn't know if your dad said nah i
think your futures in basketball I'm not
gonna let you play football well my
school did they wouldn't let us have a
football team until I graduated then we
kind of have football the next couple
years so I was also i was also we were
talking about a lot of these Chicago cub
fans got tattoos after the Cubs won the
World Series do you have tattoos no sir
I don't have any touch please never had
the urge to or I mean it feels like
eighty percent of the NBA has tattoos
why not you oh well I just my religious
beliefs but I think that there they live
off me you know I just never had it any
other way I was always talking my body
was my temple but you know I think they
look good I think tattoos are often is
just I won't have any on my body who has
the best tattoo in the NBA like the one
you'd say man I'd love to have that ah
need I'm not somebody's really been
looking at that's kind of weird playing
a basketball game and you know I'm
envira somebody's tried to but if some
guys I have unique tattoos marcin Gortat
you know yes Jordan some lawyers leg and
we always used to clown him about it
because Jordan I was kind of chubby and
you know extending a corner clients
they're jumpin and he was on a single
rose wait wait he got the older Jordan
he didn't get to eat and get the new one
you don't need the joke Jordan
you got some retired but you have to
have been there you know at the line in
your own free throw situation just look
at somebody and just notice somebody's
Tad's right well duh yeah well you know
god I obviously my team may have four
pretty cool touches to my teammates Mike
muscala and Mike Scott they both have
some very creative touches Mike Scott
actually ask every single emoji nice he
got the smiley faces the mad face he has
almost all the emojis like around his
neck yeah that might be a little
children uh yeah it's crazy but it is
actually a good idea like I thought that
was pretty cooler than a muskie he had
super mario teddy it was pretty pretty
dope he's a Dwight Howard or the Hawks
they got Cavaliers coming up now you
missed playing against Jordan by one or
two years yeah yeah yes did you ever did
you play pick up with him and did you
ever talk to him about wanting to get a
piece of him no sir i met him in high
school at his basketball all-star game
of of the NAD United you get a chance to
feed my cat all wish i would have had
opportunity to but you know i missed by
a couple years does it feel like it's
drama free in atlanta like it that
you're almost exhaling and just playing
basketball and there's nothing else that
outside interferences here oh well I
just feel like everything that you know
it's happening you know throughout my
career this it is kind of led me to this
point you know I think that you know
your past doesn't really define where
you are I think you're passing it makes
you you know it sort of essential to the
person that you will be and you know if
I look at it and I think all the
situations that I've encountered by
playing in the NBA for it just
13th season has really molded me for
this opportunity here in Atlanta and has
given me you know a little bit more
freedom do you have any conversation
with a James Harden on Saturday night ah
not really you know he's not one of the
guys that really talks you know on the
floor you know sorry I had too much of a
conversation with him but he looked good
you know he had an amazing game shot the
ball extremely well his passes were
really good at crisp look good you're 31
now 30 30 oh sorry sorry I didn't mean
to bump you up there what would you tell
a 19 year old Dwight Howard ah I was
just telling myself you know don't allow
nothing to nobody to steal your joy it's
going through life you're gonna have a
lot of ups and downs but you know never
let anybody you know still that passion
and ensure that you have for life and
for basketball and you know just enjoy
because like going by too fast you know
to deliver regrets it you know hold back
so I was just kill myself enjoy enjoy
this trauma bed being young and banner
NBA do you think you could have stayed
in orlando your whole career if you look
back on on what you had and you guys
went to an NBA Finals oh no you know i
don't think a lot of people know what
went on behind closed doors and you know
you know we never put you know that
business out there just keep it keep it
in the future there's a lot of things
that happen behind closed doors but you
know that happened in the past you know
it's made me a stronger person you know
no doubt I had a great great time in
orlando I just felt like at the time
that I asked be traded you know I just I
was too comfortable and you know I
needed to grow a little bit more had
nothing to do with you know the fans or
anything like that I enjoyed every
minute again and I'll and only you know
just saying the city
in the city grow you know you went from
a team where nobody really talked about
us and called us Orlando's tragic to
really good see you know that made the
finals and he won did a lot of great
things and I've made a lot of great
relationships with a lot of people in
orlando so not just felt like it was I
had the trig grow up and you know sorry
situation forced me to go but you look
at Los Angeles in Houston as as
opportunities look you're yet to find
positives with it but did you look at it
as something that is going to make you
grow because some could say you know
this is going to you know stunt my
growth or I'm going to be forever known
for this but how do you make it a
positive with those two stops in your
career oh well you know like i said you
know each of those situations Connor you
know molding me they kind of you know
just shifted some of my thinking you
know and it really kind of rekindled a
lot of the loving and passion you know
that I have for the game and you know I
don't regret it in a situations
happening you know you coming to Liga 18
you know a lot of things there because
you don't know you don't see you don't
do it and I'll see the world you know
just you know all our fans you know
watch TV and stuff like that they get to
see those things happen right in front
of it and uh you know it sometimes can
be kind of offers to deal with it deal
with those situations but you know just
you live in line and as you get older
matured and life you know as you know it
gets better well hopefully it's better
for you the big win against the Rockets
you got the cab's coming up in Cleveland
and we we appreciate you joining us
Dwight I always enjoy thank you thank
you for having us oh all right let's
Dwight hunter Hawks sooner the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you